[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance it was a speech to a group of
Self Serve ative 'z and he said it with
the extraordinary self-satisfaction that
has been the only constant in these nine
months of America held hostage I don't
have a schedule Trump said but if I did
have a schedule I would say we are
substantially ahead of schedule
Trump is indeed effing crazy I'm setting
aside policy for a moment because as
mindless and as evil as the baboon's
policy is it can and will be rolled back
sooner or later and his policies all
hang together if you just keep asking
yourself what would have happened here
in this country if the Germans had won
World War two I'm talking about the man
himself now his brain does not work
correctly there is a myriad of possible
explanations and we have hit them all
here congenital disease drug use any of
a dozen post concussion traumas
Alzheimer's senility lack of common
sense lack of awareness of things in the
world besides himself and endless
specific emotional or psychological or
intellectual in capacities or all of
these things at the same time in March
James Comey reportedly spread the
umbrella wide over the range of possible
root causes to him
Trump was quote outside the realm of
normal or if you prefer brevity again
quoting Comey crazy exactly why that is
is almost irrelevant this has been my
premise since I wrote a lengthy piece
for Vanity Fair last July 2016 called
could trump pass a sanity test spoiler
alert
doesn't seem like he could and it is
reflected in my book of these
commentaries which is being published
now Trump is effing crazy the title was
not picked for shock value the title was
picked because Trump is effing crazy he
said he met with the president of the
Virgin Islands he is the president of
the Virgin Islands
he claimed he came up with the term fake
the quote was I guess other people have
used it perhaps over the years but I've
never noticed it this sums him up really
is a word that seems to have first been
used by petty criminals in England in
1775 he never noticed it really even if
he meant fake news fake news appears in
a newspaper article in Cincinnati from
1890 this is not the first time this has
happened
Trump claimed he had invented the phrase
priming the pump relating to government
intervention in the economy it was used
for that reason as long ago as 1933 the
problem here is this isn't just ego
believing you invented things that have
existed since well before you were born
can be a symptom of a variety of
psychological disturbances people in the
untreated grip of bipolar disorder
sometimes literally invent their own
words and take umbrage when you don't
understand what they mean and Bigley
umbrage these are to be sure small
things individually they may even be
benign but there are so many of them he
threw paper towels to the victims in
Puerto Rico but first he had seen cans
of chicken and reportedly said quote
whoa I've never seen that before
that looks kind of good let's start
handing it out
while he was there in Puerto Rico he was
also shocked to discover that there were
water purification kits he didn't know
what they were he apparently thought the
church members showing them to him was
pitching him on an investment and
because an airforce Colonel there in
Puerto Rico said only 20% of the drivers
were showing up to deliver supplies he
was convinced apparently still is
convinced that the Puerto Rican truckers
were on strike they're not on strike
they lost their homes their vehicles the
roads on which they would drive to work
there's no strike he doesn't understand
any of this truck basically told Sean
Hannity that because the stock market is
up that means he reduced the national
debt nobody on his side has even tried
to rationalize that which is something
so stupid you would hear it from a
five-year-old suddenly thrown into an
economics class at Harvard no at Wharton
Trump has been stunned
to learn how many people live in other
countries he according to the Speaker of
the House as late as June of this year
didn't know the FBI didn't work for the
White House when they put out the latest
Muslim ban and took Sudan off of it
reporters asked him what Sudan had done
right and he said this is a quote well
the people yeah the people allowed
certain countries but we can add
countries very easily and we can take
countries away so they asked him again
what did Sudan do right and he answered
and as far as the travel ban is
concerned whatever it is I want the
toughest travel ban you can have it's as
if he'd been asked about Steely Dan it's
as if he lives in a different dimension
and only hears vague rumors about what
life is like in this one but when the
rest of us live in
he's effing crazy then there's the
sequential stuff figuring out what's
real and what's not in this
administration is like trying to shovel
smoke but reportedly this chain of
events happened a Trump tells his
cabinet he wants a tenfold increase in
the size of the nuclear arsenal
prompting Rex Tillerson to be call him a
[ __ ] or C call him an effing [ __ ]
leading Trump to D apparently challenged
tillers into an IQ test causing critics
to II assert Trump was undercutting his
secretary of state ending with F Trump
insisting no I didn't undercut anybody I
don't believe in undercutting people as
if the only things that happened in the
world were things he intended to have
happen how many levels of crazy were
there in just that one sequence of
events policy can be undone that is the
only intelligible Trump teaching moment
he seems to have been resentful that
Obama became president he was enraged
when Obama mocked him at the White House
Correspondents Dinner
he was vengeful after Obama proved his
birtherism to be ally and proved Trump
to be a liar
so Trump ran for president seemingly
selling this country out to the Russians
to get there but he did it in the way
that you or I would write a bad yelp
review or whine about a narrow
on Twitter policy can be undone
whatever Trump does we can fix it unless
it's nuclear war which is why you don't
give the crazy people the nuclear
weapons you've heard about the fake
Renoir right 12 or 13 years ago the
author Tim O'Brien was traveling with
Trump and saw hanging inside Trump's
private jet what looked exactly like the
famous painting two sisters on a terrace
by the French impressionist Auguste
Renoir O'Brien said he asked Trump if it
was an original Renoir and Trump said
yes O'Brien said I hate to break it to
you but I grew up in Chicago and the
original hangs at the Art Institute of
Chicago in fact they've had the original
since 1933 O'Brien said Trump insisted
it was the original Renoir and the
subject was dropped
well Brian said the next day they got
back on trumps plane and Trump
inexplicably pointed to the same
painting and said to him you know that's
an original Renoir for years
O'Brien heard nothing further of Trump's
original Renoir that wasn't original and
then Trump got elected and was
interviewed at Trump Tower by 60 minutes
and there on the wall was the copy of
the Renoir as Tim O'Brien says quote I'm
sure he's still telling people who come
into the apartment it's an original it's
an original Trump has to be more than
just a liar to do that Trump has to be
more than just evil
Trump has to be effing crazy resists
removed peace so to plug the book again
I have to confess I thought it would
just be a collection of these
commentaries but I think it works as a
narrative of history like a book about
the Titanic and you actually find
yourself thinking oh maybe this time
they won't hit the iceberg no they hit
the iceberg